MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Guillaume.
In a previous episode,
Mete showed us
Pic-a-Daily, the cool
picture sharing application
that you guys built together.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Hi, Martin.
Oh yeah.
That was a lot of fun to build
it using all those Google Cloud
service technologies.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
And Mete told me that you've
rebuilt the application
recently?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Well, yes.
The application used
the choreography pattern
with loosely coupled
microservices
communicating with the events.
But we felt it needed
a bit of a refresh.
We decided to convert it to
the orchestration pattern.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Orchestration pattern?
What do you mean?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
The idea is to have
somehow a central brain,
the orchestrator, that
orchestrates and calls
all the services directly.
One pain point with
the choreography
of even driven apps is that
it's sometimes a bit complicated
to figure out what's going on.
An orchestrator gives high level
view of your business processes
to track their execution.
In the loosely coupled
scenario when something fails,
you usually have to
hunt down through heaps
of uncorrelated logs
and errors to see
which particular
service failed and why.
But with an
orchestrator, you can
see the execution of your
workflow in the cloud console
and see the result of all the
service calls at a glance.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
So what did you change
to help with that?
And tell me more
about orchestration.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Google Cloud recently
released a new product
called Workflows.
It's an orchestrator.
It allows developers
to create workflows.
With a series of steps, you
can create business processes
that orchestrate calls
to several services.
And the workflow calls those
services as simple web APIs.
So we gave Workflows
a try to get a clearer
vision and understanding
of the underlying business
processes of our app.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow,
that sounds exciting.
Can you tell us more about
this new architecture
and how Workflows fit
in the big picture?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Our app business logic
isn't very complicated.
But it can be drawn as a
simple flowchart basically.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, it looks
like the Google Cloud Console
here.
The Workflow's UI shows both a
YAML definition file as well as
the flowchart diagram
of that workflow.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yep.
Exactly.
You write the YAML
definition on the left,
but you can immediately
see the equivalent diagram
on the right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
Could you describe this
particular workflow
a little bit?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Sure.
When a new picture is
uploaded in Cloud Storage,
or an existing one
is deleted, an event
is fired, one for file
creation, one for file deletion.
Those events trigger
two functions
for those two situations.
But both start our
workflow execution.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
That's how it starts.
What happens next?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: If the
file event isn't recognized,
we'll go straight to
the end of the workflow.
If the file event
is a deletion, we
remove the thumbnail
pictures from Cloud Storage
as well as the picture
metadata in Firestore.
If it's a file
creation event, we
analyze the picture with machine
learning from the Vision API
and extract information
about the labels, the color,
whether it's safe or
not to show the picture.
If it's a picture
safe to show publicly,
we store the metadata
in Firestore,
we create the thumbnail,
and the collage.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I see.
So you're saying that it's the
workflow that calls those APIs?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yes.
Calling an API is really
just a call declaration
in the YAML definition.
Notice for example
at the bottom how
we select the features of the
Vision API that we want to use.
Let me also mention the
new connectors feature
in public preview for
now, which further
simplifies calling some GCP APIs
with a dedicated call syntax.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice.
Very declarative indeed.
But there's still a
bit of code, right?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Of course.
For example, our
initial Cloud Function
was calling APIs
programmatically.
But there was a bit of logic
and data transformation
code in the middle.
So this logic part stayed but
the rest is all declarative
now.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow, that's
less code to worry about.
And also less event
handling maybe?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: True.
Less event handling.
Before with a
choreography approach,
we had three different ways to
handle events, direct events
from Cloud Functions,
Pub/Sub wrapped GCS even
from Cloud Run, and
also Cloud Events
payloads with even
arc to Cloud Run.
Now it's raised API calls.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds awesome.
So what did you learn
from this experience?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: It was
super refreshing to call
the microservices via REST
instead of different event
handling approaches.
Also, did you see the
Workflows console?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that was the one
with a flowchart and the YAML
definition side by side, right?
That seems super handy for
understanding the process
visually.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
You'll get a bird's eye
view of what's going on.
And you can gain confidence in
making changes in your workflow
without the fear of breaking
a large distributed system.
And here on this screen, seeing
all the workflow execution
is nice too.
You know at a glance
for each execution
if it succeeded or failed.
I guess it's much easier to
debug when things go wrong.
Also, we were able to
cut down some code,
even remove some
services completely
as they could be called
decoratively from the workflow.
Same thing for error handling.
That can be done
from the Workflow.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Was it easier to set
up and configure?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yes,
that was another benefit.
No need to configure
Pub/Sub, Scheduler, even Arc.
We only needed to make a REST
API call to our microservices.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Any drawbacks you noticed?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yes.
Since it's a different approach,
you got to learn it, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Also, you're actually
transforming some code
into YAML configuration.
Does that make it harder
to test and debug?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Well
to some extent, yes.
But on the other
hand, it's really just
declarative API calls.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
And in terms of architecture of
the system, any other impacts?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: We lost
some parallelism along the way
in favor of a more sequential
and predictable chain of calls.
We may have lost a bit
of flexibility as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
I guess with event
driven systems,
it's easy to extend the system.
You just fire up some
new type of event.
Right?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Yeah, true.
Or plug into existing even
streams to add new services.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
But overall, it was
a good experience?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Definitely.
If you can draw your business
processes in a flowchart,
be sure to give Workflows a try.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
And how can we learn
more about Workflows
and get our hands on it?
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Mete and I have
been running a serverless
workshop including
both event driven and
orchestrated approaches.
You can freely follow the
collabs at your own pace.
And the code of
our Pic-a-Daily app
is all open source on GitHub.
And you can also read our
article with all the details.
MARTIN OMANDER: Awesome.
It's time to read about it
and get our hands on the code.
Thank you, Guillaume.
GUILLAUME LAFORGE:
Thank you, Martin.
[MUSIC PLAYING]